I have said it a million times if the
New York Knicks hired you to do
play-by-play
I would watch every single show fact we
played a tape of you the other day and
you're yelling at the players who are on
the necks and you're going a guava jump
shot you know whose agua how our Houston
but what is hot nobody it means water I
know
jump shot was water what does that mean
here is the greatest shot ever
the full moon was like wow I like water
it doesn't touch anything it just goes
in drunk yeah when I smile Gua now Bruce
Lee said it you got to be like water be
like water and these players seem to
understand what you're saying but I'm
talking basketball to them right they
understand are the dopest and you even
yell out directions to the to the
players but what I notice is they seem
to listen to you you know them right
will yo Buster says trey songz I've been
on the blacktop
on the street you know a lot you know a
lot about bears well what do you think
is gonna happen with the next big
demerit listen this because they saw are
they building to you ya know when you
make a bold tray like KP go ahead a
junior in all of them and you free up 75
in salary cap that means the rings are
coming Mia you're gonna have fun at some
championship games